why there's no real remorse here
what do you mean there's a consequences
or apologize off social media I could
have recorded that apology and that
would have been another viral video
whether it's hate or whatever literally
hate brings money hate brings lacks
hates brings views it doesn't matter
level hate it still brings views why
would why do you prefer to do the
hateful stuff it's not like I prefer to
hateful stuff it's just like it's easier
to do the hateful what are you laughing
obviously I don't think it's fun but
you're a funny person you do think it's
funny you're a funny person you do I've
seen the videos you do you think it's
just really fun at the time I think it's
funny my fan base thinks it's funny and
it's me outside in it it's a movement
but what's something deep down what's
the movie deep down being free and not
letting anyone tell you nothing that's
why I can do all of this stuff I have
I'm the most hated person on the
internet right now
who you are okay then whatever you say
in it whatever you say most people
watches will have never heard of you now
they are that you just put it to me
they'll just look at the way you're
behaving now and I think yeah he's a
complete